things yeah our next guest is no
stranger to the TV screen actor Kirby
Howell Baptiste test starred as a
neuroscientist on the good place and an
assistant to Sandra Oh's character on
killing Eve and then as an attorney on
the drama why women kill now she's
adding Arthur to her resume she wrote
two yep that's right two new children's
books called little black girl and a
little black boy the books encourage
kids to go after their dreams and
teaches them the importance of self-love
first on CBS morning's Kirby Howell
Baptiste joins us right now good morning
how are you doing good morning I'm so
good thanks for having me of course now
you originally wrote little black girl
as a love letter to your niece I did
what was the message that you were
trying to convey to her you know I think
for me I I realize and I think a lot of
people realize as an adult that there
are so many messages that it would have
saved us so much time and so much
heartache if we if someone just told us
when we were kids it's okay to be you
it's okay to like whatever you're
thinking whatever you're feeling like
that's all valid and it felt like I had
all these things that I wanted to say
that I'd learned and I felt like this
was the best way to sort of get all that
information out and I think in writing
this love letter I really realized I was
sort of like retroactively writing to
some of the things that I wish I had
heard and wish I was trying yeah yes you
have a hard time getting into getting
the book published uh so the beginning
in the beginning I did what were you
told so a little black when I when I
first pitched little black girl to the
team I was with at that time I was told
that there wasn't an appetite for it I
was told it was like yeah I got the vibe
of very much like you're an actor you
know saying that thing
we've all had it you know and um so it
kind of it was sort of a thing that I
put aside for a little while and then
during the pandemic I was going through
you know we all had so much time for
reflection and things like that and I
was going through all the things I've
written and I've had I've got like you
know there's pilots and there's this and
there's that and I found little black
girl again and I reread it and it I
think with everything that I was
experiencing and having the time to
really digest it it actually it kind of
hit me even harder yeah so now I'm
bringing her up but this is so
interesting because you were saying you
don't have children it's unusual to see
a children's author who doesn't have
children yes well you thought what about
well I think that it seems unusual but I
think that there is a real Niche there's
a there's a market it's like the aunt
and uncle space because we occupy such a
different place in in their life in
their lives you know like we're not
their parent but we're trusted we're
part of the family you can really be
real and be honest and I and that that's
my space and to that point the first
bouncy to that point the first page of
the book struck me right I was a little
gay kid growing up in Louisiana and so
when I read this little black girl oh
the things you can do did anyone mention
the world's open to you and I myself had
a moment of
I wish somebody would have asked me that
question when I was a kid yeah what made
you start with that on page one I
honestly I think I was you you don't
know
in my mind I think that the the start of
the book is it's the whole book I think
it was just like I have so many things
to say where do you start and the first
thing is
the world is open to you like the the
world of possibilities I realize in
growing up there are so many there are
so many limitations that are put on you
from outside and as you grow older you
you the challenge is to keep sort of
like cracking and breaking and changing
and realizing that what someone
says you are is not who you are like you
define who you are and so for me it was
that's that's the whole thing the world
is open to there's so many people here
there's so many things to do there's so
there's so much there's so much joy you
don't have to be a parent to say that
you don't be an aunt or Uncle Luke and I
think you you absolutely you can be
someone that just deeply connects with
someone you can be someone who who like
I said you know speaking to yourself
recognizing yourself and hoping that
wishing that someone had said those
things to you it's so nice to see you
because number one I love your name
that's my favorite daughter's name is
Kirby I I believe the daughter's name is
when she was what I would say it's a
unique name yes
k-i-r-b-y who's my little sweetie pie
but I like in the book where you said at
some point people will tell you you're
too black you're not black enough and
what you're saying is you are really
fine the way you are and you are loved
yeah and I think that is such a good
message absolutely children of any color
yes absolutely and I found that you know
I think there's there's so many
conversations that we are just beginning
to have about race in general and which
kind of kind of just at the tip of the
iceberg and then when you go into things
like colorism and how you internalize
being darker or being fairer and what
that means and what just like you know
your you know if you're lighter you have
more proximity to whiteness therefore
you're seen as better or this or that
and I think we again the struggle is to
break out the box that Society puts you
in and it's every single day you have to
sort of
take what you've been told and assess
whether it is truth or is a fiction and
figure that out every single day anybody
told you to stay in your lane but I
think this is your lane and actress you
you're working on she's got the whole
freeway again
shut it down for me
you're working on something you're
excited about I saw you on killing
either I I am you know honestly being
creative feeds me I'm always there's
nothing that I do that I'm not excited
about if I'm not excited about it I
don't do it you don't do it I love that
you can't do it well if you don't come
to with love that's right I like how
you're thinking I sell it to other
people if you don't like exactly like we
say on our show all the time
representation matters amen and this
type of positive reinforcement is needed
much so thank you so much Kirby how
about teams little black girl and little
black boy are available now wherever
you'd like to buy your books we will be
right back